joining us on the line is governor Greg
Abbott 48th governor of the state of
Texas governor Abbott thanks so much for
joining me she'll really appreciate it
it is my pleasure great to visit with
you again so why don't we talk for a
minute about what the actual status is
of the stay at home orders in in Texas
obviously you never shut down the state
statewide you got an awful lot of flack
for that what sort of the timeline here
as to the measures taken by the state of
Texas in response to cover 19 well first
as you pointed out we never really shut
it down because we're left up and what
are called essential services and that
includes so many categories beyond just
doctors and nurses which included
construction workers manufacturing home
builders real estate agents there were
so many categories of business that were
open we're never really shut down like
so many other states did that said we
did have a stay at home policy that is
set to expire on April the 30th so
you're in just a couple of days and
after April 30th beginning May 1st we're
beginning to pumping taxes up even more
for doing business we're opening up
things like restaurants all the entire
retail sector including malls
and we're opening things like movie
theaters and museums and churches etc
churches by the way were included as an
essential service category during
essential services time period so they
also will never shut down but we're
making sure they have more latitude to
have more capacity in churches beginning
this Sunday so governor Abbott what kind
of restrictions are in place for the
retail sector or for all of the
businesses that are reopening and in
terms of crowd sizes at places like
churches well here's the deal obviously
if we were to open everything up all the
way it could lead to massive crowds
without the type of distancing practices
that really are needed because here's
the deal that the coronavirus has never
left the state of Texas still exists
here just as it exists across the United
States just as it exists across the
world and so until we have these
therapeutic grows come along and we we
are going to have to still engage in
very smart practice
to make sure that we don't promote a
flare-up in the spread of coca 19 and as
a result we want to take this on a
multi-phase strategy it's kind of like
along the lines of what some people are
seeing the president talked about a
phase in process and the way that we are
doing our phase in is if for phase one
which begins on May 1 and lasts until
the middle part of May before we hope
phase 2 will begin but for phase 1 that
the capacity for restaurants for retail
for all these different types of
entities that are being open is 25
percent capacity now is is that you know
full-bore wide open business no but is
his decisions based upon the data that
we have and also the best advice from an
outstanding medical team that is
advising us on Safeway that we can go
about reopening the economy if we can
open it up 25% for a two-week time
period
see no spread in the coronavirus and
show that we are able to continue to
control the spread then our goal is to
then take the next step and that is to
open it up to 50 percent of capacity and
see how that goes and make sure we
continue to monitor it and hopefully we
will be able to continue to contain the
spread of copán 19 and hence be able to
open up even more
one last thing real quick and that is
that we've seen this strategy work this
isn't just like pulled out of thin air
the strategy is a strategy that has been
utilized very effectively by the largest
food chain in a grocery store chain in
Texas is called h-e-b and then also used
by hardware companies like Home Depot
and in what they've been operating under
is pretty much a 25% capacity and we've
shown that through distancing strategies
etc through that capacity strategy we've
been able to allow people to go shopping
allow stores to be open while also
containing the spread of Cobra 19 donor
Abbott what sort of local
differentiation is there inside the
state of Texas obviously the state of
Texas is absolutely enormous there's a
vast difference between the population
centers of Dallas and Houston and Austin
and
rural Texas Eastern Texas so what
exactly are the are the latitudes that
are given to local leaders to determine
exactly what level of opening is
necessary no great question because as
you point out in some your listeners
know something who don't know and that
is that you know Texas obviously is a
very large state we have a total of 254
counties and in almost half of those
counties they're either been zero cases
of coverage for 5 or fewer cases of
coated and so we concluded that
obviously if you're in a county that has
five or fewer cases of coverage that's a
complete different situation than the
transmission rate that we've seen in
places like Houston in Dallas and as a
result those smaller counties that are
not affected as much by COBIT there
shouldn't be punished you know just
because there are greater challenges in
other parts of the state and so we are
allowing them to open up even more we're
allowing them to open up at this time at
50% capacity the reason why it's not
more than that is that there had been
some rural counties in Texas especially
if you would look in the Panhandle for
example where there has been an outbreak
and COBIT in some of our smaller
counties in fact some of the fastest
growth rates of copepod spread as in
some of the smaller counties in the
Panhandle the point is that it doesn't
matter if you're a large or small County
even if you're a small County you can
have fast
Cobin spread and it's something we need
to stay on top of however if you're a
small county and you have zero a few
cases we want you to be able to try to
re-energize the economy in your County
and open things up at least 50% giving
us the latitude to be able to constrain
cope with 19 in the small counties
governor Abbott there's been a lot of
focus nationally on testing and tracing
capacity obviously testing and tracing
is really designed to tamp down hot
spots and prevent the overwhelming that
health care system Texas was never
really in danger of having a health care
system overwhelmed what sort of testing
and tracing capacity are you aiming for
in Texas and how does that stack up with
the time line well like you're talking
about because Texas has had fewer
hotspots than some other places Texas
never been like New York or like New
Jersey or like Louisiana or like Chicago
or Detroit etc and as a result Texas has
one of the lowest death rate in the
United States and the death rate per
person tested positive death rate per
capita etc and as a result we're
wrapping up a well over 300,000 test
made but we are wrapping up even more as
we begin this phase in process of
opening a business and we have a team of
really good doctors doctors who are in
charge of testing and tracing at the
University of Texas Health Care System a
former FDA my head and former head of US
Medicaid and Medicare who is advising us
on this and so we have robust strategies
to be able to test and Crace and make
sure that we will be able to identify
any type of hot spots as they arise and
be able to contain it and let me
emphasize this because people need to
understand that as Texas or whatever
state you may be as states begin to open
up there is going to be an increase in a
couple of things but there will be an
increase in testing there will be an
increase in the number of people testing
positive it just kind of goes with the
territory
what we are all working to achieve is to
make sure that this not this does not
get out of control so the real metrics
that we were looking at that everybody
needs to focus on is hospitalization
rate and death rates the fact of the
matter is if you have a low death rate
like Texas if you have low
hospitalization rates with a large
capacity for hospitals to take care of
people you're really not very much in a
danger zone
and so we during this time period that
we have had this stay at home policy
with essential services being open we
had an overabundance of hospital beds of
ICU units of ventilators we never came
close today to needing to utilize all of
the resources that we had available to
us and as a result one of the most
important things that we
is to reauthorize doctors and Nerdist
nurses and dentists and our health care
professionals to get back into the game
because the the need to set aside
resources for koban 19 patients is
simply not there but the need for fellow
Texans to be treated for cancer to be
treated for heart disease to be treated
for other kinds of healthcare issues
that persist day after day those folks
they need to get in and see a doctor
they need to be treated and now they're
gonna be able to there's been governor
Greg Abbott of the state of Texas a
governor Abbott obviously we've seen the
media differentially true Republican
governors and Democratic governors
you've seen Brian Kemp and Georgia raked
over the coals you've been raked over
the coals Rhonda's Hansen Florida's been
raked over the coals meanwhile Jared
policin Colorado's a Democrat and his
planning on reopening his economy and
ways that are very similar to Texas has
basically been left alone by the media
it's what do you attribute this to this
obvious disparity well it could be the
angle that the media wants to take or I
had no idea all I can say is all that
matters to me is that we're going to be
able to open up our economy it's swiftly
and effectively as possible while
keeping our fellow Texans safe and I
think we can do that so governor Abbott
a final question for you here when you
look at you know the federal response to
all of this you're a governor who's been
interacting regularly with the federal
government we've been hearing from
governor's across the aisle that the
federal government response has actually
been quite forthcoming about all this
nonetheless then the media coverage has
been all about supposed to giant federal
failures how do you evaluate the federal
government's response in terms of what
you need in your state so let me give
your listeners a kind of a window and
the way this really works right before
getting on the phone with you I was just
on a phone call with the vice president
as well as the Secretary of Ag talking
about making sure we keep our food
chains open and our food supply is
available and keeping our food supply
safe my point is that that's the second
time this week that we've been on the
phone with either the president the vice
president world on phone typically twice
a week with the president and with
people like dr. Burks
and before I wrote
plan out I had the opportunity to both
visit with dr. Burks about it the
senator to talk to the president about
it the president said that he strongly
endorses it and supports it dr. Burks
had a chance to look at it and send an
email back saying this is a great plan
the state of Texas has my point is this
and that is we are talking to the White
House staff on almost a 24/7 basis and
so they've been very approachable very
available very helpful and this has been
a true team effort and we appreciate
everything that they have done to help
the great state of Texas and there's
been a great partnership and like we
pointed out you know we've seen that as
a statement in a bipartisan way
governors of both Republican and
Democrat state have appreciated the all
in effort and by the federal government
to help the entire country respond to
this well governor Greg Abbott of Texas
really appreciate your time and thank
you for your leadership stay stay stay
safe out there
we'll do all the best to you all god
bless america
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content